you're going first i'm daniel craig i'm
lashawna lynch and this is the wired
auto mobile complete auto complete
interview
no that was great come on that's great
it won't get any better than that
honestly it won't
[Music]
this is for me this is for you guys so
is daniel craig that's you this is
terrifying the best james bond i don't
know what i'm saying do you have to
answer do i
i'll answer yes all right oh hands down
is daniel craig left-handed
[Music]
no not today
is hanukkah a knight like what do you
mean a knight to unite people
for a living oh yes good okay great i
have a sword and everything and you i
did so on set but i don't want to say
anything is daniel craig related to
kevin costner is that a real question
yeah this is the intimate random what
the hell yes actually yes i knew it yeah
it is daniel craig oh not working is he
not working if you're live
is he alive there's daniel craig i mean
it's questionable because you might be a
hologram yes sir yes just
is that grammatically correct hi i'm
shawna lynch how to pronounce lashauna
lynch
come on lara shower now let's shine
lunch there we go how blank is
i feel like terry wogan
hell blank is lisanna lynch
how oh god oh
oh smelly how old is lashonda lynch oh
24.
thank you how he's 21 for whatever tall
is lashonda lynch how tall do you think
lashana lynch is five
ten oh
nine all right how does sean connery
feel about lashauna lynch very good no
that was a terrible look that's the best
show economy i can do
okay that's it
very good fabulous yeah fabulous feel
great about sean sean connery thinks
that shawna lynch is fab
next
okay
this story is called what daniel craig
what does daniel craig
eat paper um
i knew it anything
what
does daniel craig
so what languages does daniel craig
speak of barely speaks english what was
daniel craig's first movie it was a
movie called the power of one i watched
it it was a long time ago okay no
don't
okay what is daniel craig wearing right
now
he's wearing a wonderful outfit is
what's happening oh you're so nice what
is daniel crade
workout always daniel craig
work out
um i'm trying to work out
what the question means um
workout yeah i go to the gym
what is daniel craig like in real life
big disappointment
[Laughter]
give it he's fast
luciano lynch roll in james bond
what about it
can't tell you sorry sorry it's a secret
i'm not sorry actually watch your movie
it's great and then blank
black bio lashona lynch where were you
born
oh
it's question one london i'm trying to
get i'm trying to give this a go west
london west london where about some west
london chev's bush no really yeah that's
quite a lot of fun my whole life story
guys yeah that lash on a lynch
shoe shoes today oh my god now i know
why they're asking the question
there's a fab thanks babe can i borrow
it yes lashana lynch
martial arts oh my gosh
you know i actually did used to do kung
fu and jiu jitsu do i know kung fu you
know kung fu no
neither do i no jiu-jitsu kung fu yeah
but you really uh you really kicked ass
in this movie
just fine thank you
sharma lynch verified account
oh really what do you want her password
it's like someone's scamming you
someone's waiting for someone
through this wired interview someone
actually wants your password
can we have your back details
right
how many how many
did daniel craig make how many bond
movies did you make clearly too many
dear daniel crane i was like mine is
did did daniel craig jump out of
helicopter oh i remember watching that
well clearly i did it was on television
so it's real it's real
and the queen was with me she jumped out
as well
how did daniel craig we're going
sneak did daniel craig really meet the
queen yes i did willy
and i really jumped out of the
helicopter was daniel craig in harry
potter yes
that was was one of my favorites
actually pretty good wasn't gryffindor
it was daniel craig
a storm trooper in the force awakens
yes i don't know you just said uh
you know that's i was a speaking storm
trooper yes yeah
right what's next come on lashana lynch
blank black
lynch in captain marvel someone needs to
have a word about grammatics here
because this is like what about lashawna
legend captain marvel
speak
laton lynch and captain marvel happened
i played maria rambo in captain marvel
she was great wasn't she great thanks so
much you were you were really great
charlotte lynch track and field
yes do you know what yeah did you yeah
what did you do
track and field was i was 100
meters no what was your time
oh i don't know it's quite quick
when you're kids you know everybody wins
oh that's really great everybody wins so
that's probably from my first movie fast
girls where i played an athlete wow and
don't worry if you haven't seen it it
was my first movie and it uh was i
played yeah it was a relay team gb relay
team oh lashana lynch still star-crossed
yeah yeah
that was my first american series i need
to watch some more of your stuff clearly
danny's not watching anything he doesn't
watch tv
that was a shonda rhimes series about
post romeo and juliet after they die
what happens oh
set where
at in the time but like after they die
yeah um so after they die rosalind
rosaline and um the prince are in love
right but she is in a quandary because
she's also well she falls in love with
benvolio it made you guys i think you
should watch it i will
oh you're doing a bit how
is
daniel craig marvellous thank you where
did daniel craig grow up
um in and around liverpool yeah yeah
i love it there what football team does
daniel craig
ought liverpool was daniel craig in the
military
no oh about to say ah no there
does daniel craig
have a tattoo
does daniel craig wear contacts
wear glasses
to read with yes all right okay
here we are sorry i think you again okay
can daniel craig
sing
i feel like you can
yeah it's not kind of you know i mean
alone yes shower shower music okay sure
are
daniel craig bond films prequels
to what in casino royale you show
getting that double o status so there's
this kind of theory that these may be
prequels
sure
yeah
why not
it's a nice idea we're going to make ten
more who is daniel craig who is daniel
craig stuntman oh
jc chasey
where did donald craig go to school
hillary secondary school
that's it sure oh it's mean all right
okay
all right here we go where is luciana
lynch
from shepherd's bush i'll answer that
one she's from shepherd's bush he knows
me west london is la shawna winch
the shadow winch british she's from
shepherd's bush you can't get more
british than that this is true oh
lashana lynch face close up
what
is this actually still keep still you're
having a close-up yeah that's it they
look like you're stifling a fart stop
that
even more like stuff
there's just so many paws happening
good
i'm fine just oh jesus
i learned
that google asks a lot of questions
it's about daniel craig wow that's
profound i know thank you you are
welcome so nice to work with you you too
what was it the show
last one
darling